it feels like the same play from the nfl
it feels disingenuous they told colin
that
he has the opportunity
and that the league will
send representatives from this team but
it's a saturday before game
teams are traveling on saturdays what
head coach or jim is going to be able to
make this
trip
um
but as far as i know kyle is going to be
there and he's going to perform because
i know he's right
i'll quote malcolm x
if you stick a knife 9 inches in my back
and pull it out six it's not progress
it's still a knife on my back so we'll
see what happens
that's eric reed panther safety former
colin kaepernick teammate and close
friend of kaepernick expressing his
views about the legitimacy of the dog
and pony show that the nfl out of the
blue set up for this saturday hey can we
do it on tuesday nope it's got to be
saturday can we do it next saturday nope
it's got to be this saturday there's
been that hint of dysfunction from the
moment the sheet was pulled off of this
thing on tuesday chris and and as people
have gotten their arms around it there
is more and more evidence that something
isn't right let me give you the latest
this came up last night you've got
kaepernick's side that is putting out
there the notion that the nfl agreed to
provide a list of the executives and
coaches who will attend on saturday and
then the league is putting out via name
sources the other side of the equation
saying we never agreed to anything and
it just tells me that this is not
something that is being done for any
positive uplifting purpose this is a pr
play or a legal strategy or a little bit
of both this isn't about getting colin
kaepernick a job because if this was
about getting colin kaepernick a job it
would happen behind the scenes it would
happen through the back channels it
would happen through the result of a
horse trade where someone from the
league office calls up a team
and basically makes a subtle or not so
subtle promise of something at you
you'll be exempt from hard knocks or
you'll get this or you'll get that or
you got to work with us here just like
what happened when michael sam got cut
by the rams and peter king reported that
the league was calling around to get
someone to put him on a practice squad
that's how you do it you don't do it
through this spectacle that consumes
multiple news cycles and confuses
everyone yeah no i mean uh spot on i
mean i was hoping that there might be
something real here but as yesterday
went on and more and more information
comes out you realize it's not real it's
a sham it is i mean there's no other way
to say it yeah they're having a workout
gosh they're giving them a whole of four
days to get prepared for it oh thank you
nfl thanks for giving him four days now
he's prepared i don't doubt that one bit
all right so that's one thing the other
thing i really would like to know did
the nfl call around right before they
even released this to make sure that
teams would attend it and and get deals
done before that
you know as far as saying hey if we have
a workout for kaepernick will you send
somebody down yeah we will deal i mean
it certainly seems like it's uh some
sort of situation whether it's a deal
between the nfl pa and the nfl just to
make things look good because now the pa
is uh hey we're sticking up for our guy
and we got him a workout and things like
that i don't know there's a lot of
question marks here but it's not a good
look and and really the big thing to me
is not even that it's on a saturday it's
the fact that it's like four days notice
that really bothers me because coaches
aren't going to go no matter what you
know when i worked in new england and we
had tuesday workouts very rarely when
like free agents came on a tuesday were
there any coaches there to evaluate the
workouts it was usually always front
office people now maybe once during that
season did bill belichick come out and
watch because it was a really important
position or somebody that you know they
just wanted his set of eyes there one
more time but for the most part it is a
gm front office type thing but it just
seems odd with the hastiness of the
scheduling and everything
but here's the thing yeah they'll tape
that work out the coach can watch it
later that workout is done yes under the
direction of
the new england patriots front office
staff they get exactly what they want so
the coach can evaluate it this thing
who's who's driving this bus that's
people from the scouting combine yeah
right on a typical workout when you
bring a guy in you have him do what you
would have him do when he's on the field
you have him do things from your offense
you haven't make throws that you would
want him to make if it's a quarterback
so and and this is the other side of it
too you know yesterday different coaches
and gm's were saying whether they would
or wouldn't attend and i remember when i
saw the first one who was on the record
brian flores the dolphins coach we're
going to send somebody to this workout
it's like well if you really were
interested in colin kaepernick you pick
up the phone you call his agent and say
come work out for us here that's what's
so crazy about this any team that ever
was interested in seeing what he can do
needs to make a phone call chris he's
had zero workouts in the three years
that he's been available he's had one
visit he went to seattle in may of 2017.
and that's it it's very easily done and
a lot of these questions that are out
there about how much money he would want
or what role he would want
they've never been asked we've we've
assumed we're not we but i'm saying
people in the media assume i'm going to
get anything right now
well i later but just just that's right
but we don't even know because it's
never been no a conversation
so hoping for is that saturday maybe
gives teams the courage then to bring
him in for personal workouts like a team
like miami who the quarterback question
is real there maybe they will further
this somewhere down the line
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports